foreign
let's go back to Texas a lot of Dallas
Texas and talk to Alexis what's up
Alexis
hey how are you Dr John I'm good Kelly
just gave me an ugly look
I I spent half of my life in Houston in
the other half of West Texas and in both
places we were trained like militantly
to not like the DFW area but that's
where Kelly
that's where her heart lives right
inside of Jerry world stadium and so
alas understandable I'm glad to be
talking to a Texan how about that what's
up Alexis
so I've been with my boyfriend for over
two years now and we're starting to have
the getting engaged and getting married
talk ew I know are you excited
I am excited very cool that's awesome
but it leads to uh the question
what are some ways to have the combining
money talk and have it progress for lack
of better words positively
when he tends to double down on his
opinion
and I'll shut down or get really quiet
I think the answer to your question is
in your response to
your boyfriend's disregard for your
value system
almost a hundred percent of the time not
quite but almost 100 of the time in this
situation he also there's other things
that he just blows you off on
other things that you think are
important or dreams you might have or
values you might have that he just blows
you off
money's just one of them and it's a big
one
yeah
um most of the time people come at this
conversation very tactically when we get
married I really want to have a combined
checking account I want to have
um do all of our investment stuff
together and then the other partner is
like no way dude I want separate
checking accounts you pay these bills
I'll pay these bills we'll both pitch in
for the mortgage which by the way is a
recipe for financial and relational
disaster it's a terrible idea
um but
the better way to start that
conversation is here are a few things
that scare me to death about marrying
you
one is I'm so scared I feel so unsafe if
you have one checking account and I've
got another
I don't feel whole that way
I also don't feel safe it when you go
out all weekend and you don't even call
home I'm just making stuff up now
um
a way that I will feel safe as your wife
is if we both have a single account and
both of our paychecks go into that
account and we make a budget together
and we dream together and we create a
future together and it's not we're not
co-managers of our household
but we are in this thing ride or die
yeah and maybe asking him what scares
you
so much about sharing an account
because if he's going to get married to
you legally
if he's gonna create a human with you
sexually and biologically
the idea that I still need to hold on to
this one thing it just feels like
Madness to me
yeah see what I'm saying and so but it's
fair to ask him what scares you so much
what what is it in your soul and maybe
as a kid his
um I call it Financial infidelity maybe
his dad stole a bunch of money and spent
it like a maniac and mom was just taking
her tiny little paycheck and trying to
pay bills and keep the house afloat
maybe that happened or maybe mom was
just a reckless spender and dad was
always trying to figure out how to make
things work who knows what was going on
um but giving him an opportunity to talk
about how this thing makes y'all feel
why that's such a scary thing
um but at the end of the day I would say
this
if you don't trust me enough to share
bank accounts our relationship is not as
strong as I thought it was
and I know that's a scary caustic
statement
but I'm telling you if you were a close
friend of mine you were my sister or
something like that and you're
considering marrying somebody and this
was a deal breaker for them I would look
at you and say that's a deal breaker for
me
yes
how strongly do you feel about him
very strongly
I want you to practice not shutting down
when somebody leans up against your
value system
yeah
why do you have that value why do you
want to share accounts
everything they share accounts
I guess that's kind of just everybody
around me has always shared accounts and
I know so his parents don't share
accounts let's throw parents out the
window why do you want to
just to feel like we're both
contributing to something okay so like
it's not just his piece of furniture my
piece of furniture There You Go our
furniture and the beauty of getting
married is two people decide to dissolve
their autonomy and create something
completely new that has never existed
before and that's this marriage
and that doesn't mean when you dissolve
your autonomy that means you are living
for somebody else doesn't mean you
dissolve your identity
you're still you you still have your
cool weird things that you're into and
you still have your creativity and the
things that you like you don't dissolve
your personality but you do dissolve
your autonomy I'm living for them now
and they are living for me
and we do this thing together we're
building something new
and if you're both paying rent into this
new thing then you have a Business
Partnership you don't have a marriage
yeah business Partnerships are often an
absolute train wreck right what's it
what's his what's his sentiment why does
he say that
I think
I'm too married before and divorced so I
don't know if that necessarily has
anything to do with it no Alexis that
has nothing to do of course that has
something to do with it
so I think his fear is Justified
I get it yeah totally get it I do
understand like I understand like
him not wanting to
I guess but if he's gonna get remarried
he can't get remarried with one foot not
in the boat yeah because he put both
feet in the boat last time and the bow
got tempt over
yeah and so if he's not ready to put
both feet in the boat he's not ready to
get married
yeah you can't you can't get remarried
halfway you got to go all the way in
which means he's got to go into another
relationship with the idea that he's
going to be vulnerable again and he
could get hurt really bad again that's
what he's choosing to do
yeah and if he doesn't do that he's not
ready to get married he just wants to
play house with you
yes and I know that sucks for you I know
I know
let me tell you this there's no path
forward where you shut down and just let
and let yourself get run over
okay
you might get what you want which is a
quote-unquote husband but you're gonna
get a mess
relationally right
yes but I think if y'all sit down and
say let's dream together what do we want
this thing to look like what do we want
this whole thing to feel like and how do
we get there how do we reverse engineer
that
I think you land on
I I won't feel safe in this marriage if
we're not both
joined in our values we're not both
joined in commitment to this thing and
we're both not joined with our financial
accounts
that's just I just don't feel safe
and I recognize you don't feel safe
because you got burned before
what are we gonna do
it's a hard scary place to be Alexis I
do appreciate you having the strength
and courage to say this is a big deal to
me big deal
I want you to practice as you start to
feel yourself shut down in the future I
want you to practice saying uh I'm
shutting down I'm shutting down not this
time not this time
this time I'm gonna stand here as
uncomfortable as it is come what may my
two feet are planted in the soil in
Dallas Texas I'm gonna stand up this
time
and the more you practice it the
stronger you will get
and then you can be equal Partners in
this relationship as you'll build
something completely new it's awesome